-I would say this movie
is more disturbing
than a -- a horror movie.
-I feel like
we´ve been calling it "horror"
just to kind of prepare people,
because it´s --
-Yeah.
There are horrifying things --
-It´s horrifying, yeah.
-Yeah.
-But it´s not sort of
a classic horror film.
-No.
-But you are someone --
Do you enjoy going to a --
a sort of
more classic horror film?
-No, I can´t --
I saw "Haunting in Connecticut"
in, like, 2009,
and I was scared
for three years.
-Now this is funny
because I know that
"Haunting in Connecticut" is
the film that freaked you out.
-It really did.
-That´s on --
That´s on nobody´s list
of the scariest movies.
-I know. Nobody knows
what I´m talking about.
-Yeah, we have a -- I got
a poster of "The Haunting" --
-This movie is scary as [bleep]
-There´s the poster.
I will say the poster looks
pretty scary.
-[ Laughs ] It is.
All right.
-What´s -- What´s coming
out of his mouth?
-When spirits harden
when you´re being possessed,
they come out of your mouth
like a root.
-Oh, wow.
-And it´s really scary,
scary [bleep]
-And this happened
in Connecticut.
[ Laughter ]
I noticed this, which --
this says right here --
-"Some things
cannot be explained."
-Oh, but here --
here´s what it was --
-That´s what gets me.
-"Based" --
-"Based on true events."
-But, by the way,
when I saw this,
I´m like,
"No, it it´s [bleep] not."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Based on true events?
It´s like based on, like,
one of those peanut cans
where a snake comes out.
[ Laughter ]
Like, nobody´s ever like,
"Oh, yeah,
that case where
the spirit´s root hardened
and then came out
of that kid´s mouth."
In Hartford --
it happened in Hartford.
-I wish I had had you in 2009.
-Yeah.
I could have taken the edge
off it right away.
-I was -- I could not pee
without running into my bed,
"They´re coming!"
-Oh, my God.
And this is -- you were not --
that´s not long enough ago for
you to be a child about this.
-I was like 20 or 21.
-Yeah, that´s not okay.
-I´m bad at math.
How old was I -- 19?
I don´t know.
-So, this --
-I got to -- I can´t
sit up straight anymore.
I don´t care if I look bad.
-Yeah, that´s all right.
You can give up. That´s fine.
[ Laughter ]
So, this is an incredible cast.
-Yeah.
-Outside of yourself,
Javier Bardem,
Ed Harris, Michelle Pfeiffer --
stunning, stunning.
-Oh, oh.
-Was it -- Was it fantastic
or intimidating or both
to work with Michelle Pfeiffer?
-I mean, it was fantastic,
but, like,
I couldn´t talk to her
for like, you know, three days.
-Yeah.
-And then I´d be like, "So,
what did you have for breakfast,
and what did you have
for dinner last night?
Do you take any vitamins?
So..."
-Is that because you --
-She´s just stunning. Her eyes
are the color of the Caribbean.
-Yeah.
-She´s just --
And she´s so talented.
And I spiked her iced tea
one time.
[ Laughter ]
-Now -- Now, why would you
spike her iced -- iced tea?
-I hope I don´t seem
like an alcoholic.
[ Laughter ]
-No one´s
getting that vibe off you.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, no.
Ohh!
I´ve been working very hard.
I haven´t been drinking because
I´ve been working every day.
I´ve actually never worked
in this state before.
I´ve never been this hung over
at work.
Normally I don´t have to work
the day after a premiere.
-Yeah.
-So last night --
-This is -- by the way --
-I just totally --
-I hope you don´t consider what
you´re doing right now work.
[ Laughter ]
-Of course not.
-Like, you can show up here --
-I´m here by choice.
-Yeah, exactly.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-This could be big, though.
-Oh.
-Cheers again.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I called Paramount.
[ Both laugh ]
I called them.
-You -- Yeah.
-I was like,
"Get me on something!"
-You called up the publicist
and said, "I need to --"
-I did. I got to.
I know -- I know the premiere
was last night, but still.
-Oh, I mean, yeah, this is --
this will be big for the film,
though --
the fact that you´re here.
-Oh, God.
-I wish I was in sweatpants.
This is awful.
[ Laughter ]
-Next time you´re here, full
permission to wear sweatpants.
-Okay, thanks.
-You also --
a trailer for a new film
that you´re in --
Is it "Red Sparrow"?
Is that the name of it?
-Yes.
-Just came out.
You shot that Budapest. And --
-Yeah.
-I have another drinking story
about Budapest, but...
-I know.
So, I heard you got in a --
what --
you got in an altercation?
-I got in a bar fight.
-A bar fight in Budapest.
-I got in a real bar fight.
-That seems like a dangerous
place to get in a bar fight.
-[ Chuckling ] I mean, for him.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-First of all,
shout-out to Dream Team --
you know who you are.
We were at a bar,
it was Beer Night,
and we -- we had a ton of beers,
and we were all drinking.
And this one guy --
I was drunk, which is rare.
-Yeah.
-I was drunk, and this guy
asked me for a selfie.
And I was like,
"No. Thank you, no."
And then he was like,
"Please, my girlfriend
will never believe you."
And my friend was like,
"If your girlfriend
won´t believe you,
then she´s not the one."
[ Laughter ]
And -- And so we were like,
"Just go away."
And then he goes,
"Yeah, well [bleep] you."
And then I just --
I don´t know --
something in me just snapped,
but it couldn´t have been
the alcohol.
And I was like, "Did you
just say, ´[Bleep] you´ to me?
Did you just say,
´[Bleep] you´ to me?"
And I, like, grabbed him,
and I took beers,
and I started dowsing them
all over him.
And then he was --
weirdly, he had a suitcase...
-Uh-huh.
-...and, like,
went straight to the bar.
And I was like,
"Is that your [bleep]?!"
And I started pouring beers
all over his suitcase.
And my friend Chris came up,
grabbed me from behind.
He goes, "Don´t waste beer.
Don´t waste beer."
And I instantly relaxed.
I was like, "Of course.
What was I thinking?"
-Yeah. The only --
I really just hope...
[ Applause ]
Yeah, that´s fantastic.
-Thanks.
-And a good cautionary tale.
-Well...
-I certainly hope,
at some point,
one of that guy´s friends
got a picture of that.
[ Laughter ]
-My friend was in the bathroom,
and he came back.
He´s like,
"Did you guys see that guy?
He was all wet and crying."
[ Laughter ]
-Well, it serves him right.
Thank you for being here,
as always.
-Is it over?
-It´s over. Yeah, you did it.
-All right, bye.
-You did it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
-Go get your sweatpants.
Jennifer Lawrence, everybody!
"Mother!"
in theaters everywhere tomorrow.
We´ll be right back
with Caitriona Balfe.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh!
-[ Laughs ]
♫♫